so hello everybody i am sitting here
with ben hatke ben is a best-selling
author artist he is mostly known for his
series zeta the space girl and also
mighty jack
i was
introduced to his work by andrew gould
whose opinion is always unfailing to me
whatever he he suggests to me i
immediately look at it and i found in
his stories with my kids as well just of
just a wonderful boisterous storytelling
deep understanding of storytelling and
of and of myth and a fairy tale but also
connection to science fiction just very
well-rounded storytelling so if you have
kids even as adults i enjoyed them
reading them as adults myself so i'm
really happy to be able to talk to him
he has a new book
coming out next month called julia's
house goes home which is a third part of
a series of picture books so you can
also check that out and make sure to get
that
as as the months coming along so i'm
looking forward to this conversation
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
so ben thanks for thanks for agreeing to
talk to me i was a little surprised that
you agreed because you know you're kind
of a big shot i guess in the in the
the art world uh but i was really and i
found out that that your wife at least
you and your wife have watched my videos
and that kind of follows me so that was
a very interesting connection for me yes
you were a big shot in our household
apparently well i'd say apparently no
but i mean like i i've often walked into
the kitchen and been like oh it's
jonathan joe's voice again
so yeah it's funny how these things work
because it's the same when i got the
zita and mighty jack books then my kids
just loved them like devoured them and
then then the same thing when i told
them that i was going to talk to you
they were like oh my dad's a big shot
because he gets to talk
i'll make books yeah it's just funny how
it works uh and so i mean tell us a
little bit about about yourself how you
kind of fell into this to this world and
uh and then we'll just jump in
um
you know um
i was thinking about like well not that
i'm thinking about this all the time but
i was actually thinking about it
yesterday because i was making a um my
dad has a youtube account now really yes
he is an architect and he he just and
he's an architect that um
oh boy if he listens to this he he's
tried to retire a few times but it never
sticks right he's he's always doing he's
always doing stuff and he's
started a little youtube account um the
frog pond school of design which has its
own um backstory but it's it's
interesting architectural tidbits all
the videos are like three minutes and
you're like what is an inglenook uh how
do we control sway in very tall
buildings right um
just really like
like stuff like and then stories from
the renaissance but um but i've been
trying to like promote these because i
really like him doing these videos and i
was thinking like and i was writing a
little bit about it and i was like and
my dad of being an architect is the
first person who
because i i deal in story storytelling
but
i think a lot about words and pictures
and
how they dance or work together or
move together tell stories um
and so like
you know my own like my own legend that
i tell myself about this is was with my
mom who would always bring me the
library because she would always she had
a big
um
uh cloth bag that she would always fill
the weeks reading um had a lot of
stories read to me as a child a lot of
raw doll a lot of the narnia chronicles
um but the bfg was huge in our house and
now i'm now reading it to my daughter
but my dad always when i would ask him a
question he was always much more
inclined to pull he had always would
have pens and uh note cards in his in
the breast pocket of his shirt and he
would always like pulling out he was
more comfortable explaining something
through drawings
um as as comfortable as with word and so
that i feel like in my deep deep
recesses in my brain that's where i
realized like like drawing is
not only something that you do for fun
but it's like this incredibly powerful
uh form of communication
and um
and then you know obviously like so many
of us i i
would read the sunday funnies in the
morning that are the or like no the
comic strips every morning right like um
and you know garfield moved to calvin
and hobbes which was which was brilliant
yeah
calvin and hobbes moved to um
uh you know a lot of the marvel stuff i
i found like spider-man comics got
really into that but another big one was
elfquest yeah by wendy and richard peany
and i would i had the great memories of
riding my
bike up to the book used bookstore when
i was like 10 11
12 and looking through the stacks trying
to find because i didn't have the
collections i would have to find oh
you'd have to find the actual comics
background the marvel reprints and like
so there were always gaps in my
knowledge of well that's not part of the
story and and so also and it was the
first thing that really showed me like
long for that was my first experience
with like long-form storytelling in in
comics
um
yeah so you know uh
comics ended up always being something
that i could uh
you know you get i don't know as you
grow up you get positive reinforcement
with certain things whenever i made
comics people enjoyed them so i made
more comics um and
you know i ended up um
like even in college like
one thing i i did quite a bit was i
would always tape a sheet of 11 by 17
paper up in in our bathroom and like our
shared dorm bathroom and i had this
ridiculous comic that i would just keep
adding to
and and that's positive reinforcement
too because i would hear people laughing
from the bathroom yeah yeah yes now i'm
going to put more into this comic in our
bathroom yeah like other people would
come use it just kind of for that
um
yeah and then
yeah and and so yeah so there's like the
sort like and sort of like i'm thinking
a lot about influence and stuff and
there's definitely just a thread of
story that runs through
i don't know runs through my life even
though i didn't like i didn't do
art school i studied history um
but then um you know when i was doing
freelance um
art and design after i was married um
and just starting out i was doing just a
lot of like like design work like
photoshop work and and illustrations for
textbooks things like that
and then um
got to this point where i wasn't getting
any better but at that point i had met
um
the
group of artists online the flight
flight guys uh um so i got i kind of got
my break there was an anthology called
flight
where a bunch of artists of different um
we all seem to have like a similar we
all grown up loving the
um the studio ghibli movies yeah
rocky movies and and we all kind of had
a similar sensibility and at that point
there wasn't
much in the way of
middle grade comics like young people
um this was and so this is like all
these guys are there's kazukishi who
went on to do the amulet series like
reina who does smile and all these
things oh okay
so the whole this whole kind of movement
came out of this message board that
kazoo started and this anthology of
comics that we all put short stories
into
um simultaneously around that time we
spent a year in italy in my wife's um
grandmother's house which is you know
like vaca like like she had passed away
but um we kind of was restoring that
house in the mountains and so i spent
some time uh during that time in
florence um so the other the other side
of that coin is i was spending a lot of
time um
learning to paint like like portrait and
figure painting
sort of a school that was you know
connected to the lineage of john singer
sergeant and stuff like this
so um
so yeah those are kind of the two sides
of that coin and then
in comics just
round out a kind of a story that i've
let go um
in comics you know um
the manga comics kind of were coming in
and and becoming very popular and
uh jeff smith's bone i don't know if
you're familiar with yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay the bonus it was getting big too
yeah but it was over like it had ended
and scholastic picked it up and there
just wasn't a lot else and made and and
there were there were tr like
mostly comics were still like superhero
comics and they have their own
distributor like the diamond distributor
but
uh mainstream book publishers were like
um seeing the
scholastic get the money from bone and
humongous stuff coming over and they're
like well there's there's money in these
comics
and we just thought like all the flight
people happened to be in that in the
right space
um to sign up these books um really on a
song like what had i done i had done a
few short stories i had done um z to the
space girl as a web comic but not a
like not a
reliably updating web comic like there
wasn't a ton but um but they signed me
up for a book because they they wanted
books and um
yeah and from there i just i was able to
keep doing it um and yeah so now i'm
making comics and picture books and pro
stories and other stuff yeah well it's
interesting because hearing you mention
your influences and just the kind of
zeitgeist around what you were doing all
of a sudden it it just makes so much
sense you know in terms of bone and uh
all this imagery like even when you talk
about miyazaki i mean i realized how
then all of a sudden it hit me that zita
is really
the kind of feminine character that you
find in a miyazaki movie this kind of
just boisterous joyful
in someone who influences others too
like who has this kind of magnetism that
is able to
to kind of attract others to to her
cause you know and she anyway so so it
makes a lot of sense i really it really
and elfquest as well in this kind of
long form
um there's something about your work
really when you even when you talk about
your father and this architecture side
to it
uh like i really feel that in the even
in the page compositions you really have
a sense of flow
in terms of storytelling but also in
terms of general composition for the
pages are composed as standalone images
you could almost think of them that way
which is something that not a lot of
comic artists are able to pull off very
well the architectural element is there
very it's present in the sense that the
even the comic pages the way that you
compose them there's a sense of unity in
the the page itself and so there's this
flow
of movement because it a lot of them
like i was looking at them i was reading
again the mighty jack series yesterday
there's a flow of movement
uh constant movement and especially in
the jack story where it's just this it's
almost like a chase story right it just
kind of moves the whole time but then
this ends up being composed within the
pages and you feel this flow of the
story in the in the composition of the
the panels but also the pages themselves
so that's a it bring makes it very
compelling to read oh i'm i'm glad you
find that because like i put i that's
something i think about a lot
composition is is just like is something
it grabs the hold of that that geeky
fine-tuning part of your brain where
you're like i can do this right i can do
this better um and i think a lot about
the um
and the flow i think a lot about the
flow of an eye through the page like you
say i think a lot about the the top
uh left-hand panel i i designed my pages
as spreads yeah so i don't do individual
pages i when i do my thumbnails i'm
looking at an open page every time and i
think a lot about the
top left hand panel whatever's going on
the top hat left and whatever's going on
the bottom right and then wiggle you
across the the whole spread that way
and and also just keeping like it's
interesting
to me i don't know if it's interesting
else but like i really do um
like there's so much you can do with
composition and there's so much you can
do that can make it even more um
as with pros you can you can
you can have difficult to access pros
which is also very rich right or you can
have like i always admire authors like
neil gaiman and c.s lewis and stuff like
that who who write richly but with
with simple accessible prose um the
hobbit is an example
the difference between the hobbit and oh
gosh what's another example i i like the
ryan jacques redwall books but i found
them
really difficult to read aloud
um but then like the hobbit like even
when i'm tired if if i got if i'm going
to read a lot of chapter of the hobbit
i'm like yeah i'm in it's fine i can it
kind of it's it flows it's beautiful but
it's it's got um it's not overly
complicated yeah
that's what i think i want my comics to
be accessible to non-comics readers
right um
i've noticed like uh
and this is a real side but it
it kind of ties in um i'm very excited
for the uh marvel is doing a short
series of hawkeye
disney plus
and i love it and it's they seem to be
using a lot of the matt fraction david
asia um
a series run on hawkeye to influence
this show which is one of my favorite uh
superhero comics uh of all and because
it's because it is
minimalist in its drawings but like
super rich and interesting and it's um
in what it's doing with with composition
and there is one specific one where the
dog solves a murder mystery
and you're getting everything from the
dog's perspective
and and so it's all symbols of what he's
smelling and um it's very close to black
and white like it's the color palettes
way down
when people are talking it's all
scribbled out except for words that the
dog would
pick up on yeah yeah go uh yes uh clint
um whatever it is and and it's it's it's
a miracle that it's legible it's a
miracle that you can read it it's also
kind of like it's d it's hard to read
like like i think it's not beginning
comics readers reading but it's it's so
interesting and i like i read that when
i was like oh i didn't wow i didn't know
you could do that and um it's pretty
brilliant
uh
so yeah there's something about when i
think about the your pieces too i mean
when i think about bone it just makes a
lot of sense there's there's a sparsity
of words
and a lot of emphasis on character
making the making the drawings also not
kind of like the marble chiseled type of
drawing makes makes the characters more
accessible immediately because you're
able to tap into caricature and to you
know just having the shape of the
character be
related to their
their personality so you don't have to
you don't have to explain it a lot you
just see them and then they they catch
you and then they they can enter into
the action right away without having to
um without having to give backstory or
to to talk about you know what their
motive or try to show their motivations
you almost get it from the drawing
itself so it creates this varsity that
you're able to keep the action moving
the whole time with very few words and
not a few but like very sparse words and
but you follow the story completely
like how much story can i tell before i
get to the words um because
um one of the front you know like the
other other concept i think about a lot
is is you know art is usually defined by
its its limitations right and wonder is
when um
when you create something within those
limitations that seems impossible so
when uh that's why we're
that's why we get obsessive about the
soft drapery and flesh in marble
sculptures right it's it's it's crystal
it's marble but but somehow they're
pulling softness out of the hardness um
and that's why uh
that's why everybody geeked out about
perspective when they finally crack
perspective in um in renaissance
painting like because like it's like now
we've got it's a flat thing but it's got
depth oh my gosh you know like that's
magic there and um
with comics it's like
one of the challenges is that you know
you've got a page and you're pressed for
space and the words um
will crowd very very easily right um
crowd out what
and so the words and images have to be
working together and one of the ways i
one of the things i think about a lot is
gesture like
uh
like um
like the way we read each other's
gestures and body language right body
language how much how much can i tell
you about what's going on with the
character they don't have to say i'm
angry um
if if they say that
then i'm not doing my job you're not
making a comic right or at least it's
it's it's reduced from what it could be
so one of the things like that really
impressed me that i enjoyed seeing in
the both stories both the zeta and the
jack stories is the manner in which you
play
with the relationship between adventure
and risk or
danger and possibility you know in the
mighty jack story one of the main
tropes is that they built they
grow this garden and this garden is like
an alien garden and it is it is it is
murderous like it's super dangerous and
it could kill them but then out of this
this kind of murderous dangerous wild
garden they're able to gather power
let's say they're able to kind of get uh
both power and then let's say test
themselves in a way that refines their
character um and so i i mean i think
it's it's important to understand that
to me it's something that i i found very
beautiful at least for a kid's story
especially in a world where
kids are just inside all the time like
we this is our world like we have a
world of safety let's say where people
are obsessed with safety but you seem to
kind of explore this danger as also
possibility for development let's say i
don't know if you want to talk about
that a little bit
yeah and also yeah um
yeah and also it's like expanding their
world right like the garden ends up
being a gateway to another world and um
and it's just making these kids world
larger
and
um
yeah i mean that was
that was the
the kind of the crux of that book and um
and that
especially when also jack's also
essentially a caretaker right so like
he's also got this question of like it's
not just me
um
maybe he on his own as a 14 year old kid
would be like sure let's let's let's go
crazy it's just me on the line right but
he's got he's got maddie to look after
and um so that to me that was an
interesting question like where does
your um
responsibility uh
where
like that that that fuzzy space between
responsibility and
i don't know engagement with the world
right um and it is a good question it's
not i don't think i think it's a good
question for all times it's it's
um
yeah because even with his sister maddie
who for people who don't know is
autistic it kind of needs to be
to be uh
she needs to be watched and she needs to
be taken care of you know the garden
this dangerous space even for her ends
up also being the place where she
increases her she has a moment where she
speaks because of this garden like she
has these little moments where she seems
to kind of increase herself
and even discover this kind of secret
power secret language that she has you
know to to talk with the dragon there
all these little moments with maddie
where
you see her kind of become more as you
said even though she's someone who's
fragile and is maybe more in danger yeah
right jack letting her go into this
dangerous world is also what makes her
more more as a person
and i don't think there's an answer
exactly where the balance is and the
book you have you really do it's
wonderful because you play with that
because the garden at some point does
become it's so dangerous that it could
basically seems like it could just
destroy everything so jack has to like
burn it down but then
there's also a sadness which is that
okay now this possibility that we had
given ourselves and lily is furious with
him for burning it down exactly even
though it's obviously murderous when you
see it like this this monster coming out
of the ground like okay this is also
it's also obvious that it's like it's
it's a magical thing that is beyond like
anything that they'll ever come across
probably in their lives again so it's
also like they're both
they're both right they're both
i don't know at least they're both
acting
they're both answering that question
and neither of them
completely wrong i guess i don't know
although lily's like lily is a little
bit sneaky like she has been
stealing seeds from the garden and
growing her own in her basement um which
is funny
to me yeah exactly but so there's
there's all of that in the story because
there's this play also this is something
that i explore a lot in my channel where
you have these kind of dangerous
monsters but then some of the monsters
are you could say on our side
and then some of the monsters are on the
other side and so there's this interplay
for example with the image of the dragon
who is obviously extremely dangerous but
then also ends up being an ally against
the the giants and the same with the
goblins where the goblins are obviously
very dangerous and the goblin king is a
very scary
character but then
but then they're able to kind of turn
the goblins around and they become like
a like a tool to stop the giants from
the giants from taking over and then
these demons whatever like it just
increases right it's like these you have
these i often talk about layers of
monsters in the world where you have
your monsters and then scary monsters
and then cosmic monsters that are
further up and you need to kind of be
attentive to the monsters that are on
your side because sometimes they're
annoying
and they can be a little dangerous but
if you just get rid of them you're
basically removing
a veil and then the bigger monsters are
coming for you
and it's hard to it's hard for people to
think that way because we tend to
how can i say this like it's it's easy
to
it's easy to see how people that are
sometimes on the margin on on in many
ways
are annoying you know and so we want to
kind of cut them off but we don't
realize that there there's more there's
more on the other side like there's
bigger bigger things and stranger things
let's say
yeah and i like that i like to play with
the idea that
just because something looks monstrous
doesn't make it a monster right like it
doesn't make it evil doesn't make it
evil yeah yeah for me monsters are never
evil like well not never i mean they're
not the idea of a monster is just
something wild or something undefined or
something that is beyond your
understanding and the way you mention it
and so it's not necessarily like the
cherub for me in scripture is a monster
like the cherub that guards the the ark
of the covenant you know um and we have
the saint saint christopher who's this
dog-headed saint who's like obviously a
monster so we have these like holy
monsters and then their gargoyles are a
good example of kind of
monsters on our side or holy monsters
that are not evil they're just monsters
you know
they're there to stop the they're there
to stop evil things that are bigger
monsters that would want to invade let's
say the space
yeah no i do i like i like my saints
wild that's cool
i can't i i like i did um if you poke
around i forget where i posted it but if
you poke around i did a saint nicholas
once
um
that like because he's uh archers
sailors uh thieves and prostitutes right
yeah
and i'm like oh that's a that's a that's
a great combination like who is this guy
who would this guy be
if if i was making the character right
like and i gave him like a wizard's
staff and a huge sword and a big old
coat
yeah well there's this the image of you
see this image of saying nicholas right
that slaps arius is one of the favorite
memes to come out during christmas time
you have a sense that saint nicholas is
something of a
not he's something of a defender yeah
that's why he defends kids and he
defends the the marginal let's say yeah
um and so
tell us a little bit about what the
inspiration is behind some of your
stories because obviously you have this
interesting mix of of a fairy tale kind
of myth making with science fiction it
all kind of comes together in a very
seamless way
yeah it's um
that's the soup right like that's um
the thing about that a lot um
because the story i'm working on now is
an underworld story and it's a little
bit
structurally
um i had a big meeting about it and like
like everybody wanted it kind of latched
on to to this element where it's
structurally like they were like this
isn't the kind of story where you
examine the plot or the structure very
closely because
it's very out it's very alice in
wonderland it's very dream like like
there's it's not like uh
it's not like a three-act structure
um
kind of story
but
but visually like i'm like doubling it's
visually gonna be pretty dense and like
in that way i was like doubling down on
what where does all this come from and
like visually it's truly the furniture
of my brain and a lot of these things
he's kind of actually this kid is
traveling down into this underworld he
actually ends up traveling back
kind of through art history in a way
through human history but kind of
through art so um
um so anyway it was on my mind like
like
where where some of the stuff comes from
or what kind of furniture is in my brain
and it's
it's a lot it's like
in storytelling i like to keep a lot of
things um
kind of subconscious
so
um and then like once you get the story
down you're like oh that's where that
comes from so a lot of it's just like
but
i think part of the job of the
storyteller is always is living right
like like you can't just hole up and
make stories uh you have to live and
experience and take in and take in and
you're kind of a conduit um
always always taking in and then um kind
of
weeding out and seeing what sticks in
your own mind and then
kind of digesting all of that and then
telling your story
with the voice that only you have
but
the like like a lot of what informs your
voice is is um
is this is the things that have stuck
have hold help that have you know
managed to to stick in there and hold
dear yeah one of the one of the things i
tried to explain is that storytelling
let's say the pattern of storytelling
just come from attention
you know you can understand
the ancient myths or the myths that have
come down to us or the bible stories or
these ancient stories
the reason why we we have them is
because
they grab people's attention and then as
they were transmitted
that attention was maintained that is
that there's a capacity to pay attention
and so you can imagine how stories
refine themselves with the tension that
is those stories that are able to get
keep our attention will survive the
generations and those that aren't will
just kind of fade away um
and then even the stories themselves
will end up being refined because
as they kind of progress in time some
things become idiosyncrasies and you
have to modify them so that the story
can be remembered so you end up having
these really pure stories with time that
just kind of happen on their own through
a process of natural selection you could
call it but then you also have that in
yourself which is that the things that
you remember
there's a reason why you remember them
they're not just for sentimental reasons
there's there's something about them
which we're able to grab and keep your
attention and so and in that laboratory
in your brain or in your in your
experience you know to gathers that
together and to bring out stories
without doing it
too deliberately you know and so let's
say the heroes like the hero's journey
comes out without having to plan it like
where people say oh how does this fit
with uh with the hero's journey let's
say but if you're if you're an intuitive
storyteller then that pattern will just
appear almost out of
it just makes sense because it's this
just the things that made you care about
stories in the first place
yeah yeah
so there are a couple threads i guess
to that um
i'm not trying to decide which one to go
with first
one of the things uh the hero's journey
stuff is is interesting but
but just evolution of story is
to go to the earlier point evolution of
story is something um
because stories stories live and they
are passed down and
there's there's an ev there's an
interesting way that they you know
evolve through time
um based on because stories gain power
as they're retold
and but they also gain like they're also
plastic right they they they're shaped
and they move as they're as they're
retold and
one of the things i take issue with
when i sometimes i hear like you know
like
you know like like corporations are
owning like the stories now
but it's not entirely true
because
there's so much
cosplay and fanfic and
um
freedom of people taking these stories
and making them their own right like
i'm doing my version of captain america
um
and and
they're like
like one of my favorite um
like fanfic like one of my like one of
my favorite fan fiction comics that i've
run across is
um and it's gone now because the person
stopped making it and then it got old
enough that it it's now on uh the
wayback machine i think you can still
find it it was called steve rogers
american captain and it was his it was
the the because in the in the early
comics he is an art student before he
gets the the super soldier serum and so
and even they kind of referenced that
there are a couple scenes in
the marvel movies where he's sketching
yeah right and so they kind of call back
to that but there's this one where like
there's this comic and it's like a
journal comic it's like a diary comic
and it's steve rogers is woken up in the
modern age
he thought he was going to die in that
plane crash he was like this is my death
and so it it picks him up and it's like
okay he's this powerful guy but he's
also got ptsd from war and he's also
catching up on art so he's like i'm
going to make a journal comic about my
experiences and it's just the most
touching
thing where somebody latched onto this
character and
humanized him so much like as a person
and there's a there's one thread where
he goes to a gallery show with pepper
potts and they
sit outside it's very human it's like
there's no battles or anything in it
they just sit outside talking about
their lives and
at one point he gets he gets kind of
worked up about something and she's like
that's really scary
because
and you realize he's realizing in his
mind he's still
there's part of his mind that's still 95
pounds right yeah he doesn't realize
that sitting next to pepper if he's like
and then
that she's going to be like you can you
can you could kill with iron man yes
um so so like there's a lot of people
doing that and like like
just taking these stories and making
them their own um but then with the
hero's journey
um i got into this once a discussion
about this um
kind of with it with like a group of
onlookers about the hero's journey and
stuff like that and like i don't i feel
like i never quite made
i feel like i have since kind of refined
my point about it um i think that
some of the story structure stuff that
works time and again um because there
are a point there is a
there are valid points that like a lot
of the
some of the hero's journey stuff
can carry some
cultural baggage right
um
that
you know
every new time can re-examine and say
how much of this we want to keep but i
think at a base level
this idea of
the structure of the hero's journey
um and the way star wars plugs into it
stuff like this i feel like that is a
little bit like i feel like it exists
the way
rhyme scheme exists yeah
outside of us right um you can have all
these discussions about poetry but you
have to admit like abba
rhyme scheme
is a is a thing it's just it's just a
it's a it exists whether you want it to
or not and so
um
so you know all the
um all the cultural stuff around it
aside the idea of the hero starts out
takes one step back
takes two steps forward
big
big thing
new status quo right like you move from
status quo
um
like to we see we see how what the
status quo is there is the call to do
something different
there's the refusal of the call
there's the acceptance of the call
um
things get worse and worse and worse
until they reach a breaking point
now we're in a new status quo like
that's the hero's journey and it's at
its like most baseline level
um
so i feel like like like that just
that's just there and i and i get i
it is exciting to me to look at that as
a as a basic rhyme scheme for
storytelling and realize that you don't
have to tell stories that way but it's a
super basic rhyme scheme that you can
know and also now that you know it what
interesting things can you do with it
yeah
and a lot of the stories like
a lot of the edgy stories or let's say
the experimental stories or the more
modern stories what they're doing is
that they're not doing that basic story
on purpose to make you notice that
they're not doing the basic thing so
even when you kind of go away from this
you know like let's say like you said
like situation problem resolution or
return to a sid another situation
sometimes it doesn't mean that there's
an actual resolution of the problem but
a transformation and then to another
state it's like
and then if you look at crazy you know
data type storytelling or people try to
break that that that structure you
notice oh you're trying to break that
structure and then the structure still
continues to exist because you keep
trying to break it so any experimental
story ends up
in a way even reinforcing that pattern
because you notice it as an exception
you see it as something which is trying
to be different and so it just comes
back to it just it just becomes like you
said almost like a
it's almost like the pattern of
breathing it's just like how you even
recognize that something is a story is
because
there's
you know i keep i keep
telling people that the world is full of
facts right the world has a million
amounts of facts so if you string them
together
and for people to remember it you it's
not arbitrary the way you do that it has
to have a certain pattern or else people
won't even be able to recognize it as a
unit right only being able to say that's
a story it's a it's it's framed with a
beginning and an end right it has
characters that have some kind of of con
continuation inside or at least some
theme or something which holds it
together um or else it then it looks
fragmented and and and we struggle to
even remember it let's say
sure sure um
but i do think they're like i like i do
think there are multiple there are many
stories right and like so i do think
like
i do think that you know like these
stories that i think of as as rhyme
schemes um
i still have to admit that there's jazz
right like there's still
uh
and and those kinds of experiments
like you know breaking out of of you
know i'm not a musical expert but
breaking out whatever came before is
what leads us to to jazz which uh brings
in its own richness in finding
i don't know in in like new patterns new
new ways of doing things like i feel
like the same thing happens in in
mathematics and in
you know physics and stuff like this
um
the other thing though that called in
mind with what you were saying was um
another thing i've been thinking about a
lot is um
stories as survival information coded
survival information um this is a
something that um
i don't know if you're familiar with uh
brian mcdonald and and he's written a
book called invisible inc
uh he's got a podcast called the you are
a storyteller podcast really good and
he's like a master he's he's he's he's
masterful at talking about about story
he's a great uh screenwriter and
storyteller um
but he talks about stories as as sort of
as um at their root like you know at a
fundamental like
almost evolutionary level it's coded
survival information you've got the
libreo tar pits you can find um you know
saber-toothed tiger in the tar pits or
no you can find like okay you find a
mammoth in the tar pits you can find a
saber-toothed tire on top of the mammoth
and the tar pets you don't find a person
on top of that saber-toothed tiger on
top of them because they have a story
about the tar pits i saw this thing go
in there it didn't come out right story
as simple as that um and then like and
then there are certain story like the
another proof of the or like example i
guess of this would be like
um i can say um
uh the tortoise and the hair and you're
like slow and steady wins the race right
that it like it like and if i had if i
sit down a child and i say now if you go
sometimes the slower route is the better
route to win the re like they're not
going to remember that but if you
teleport us in the hair
it's in there right and it's in there
and now that you say it and they
immediately are thinking so but
anyway uh so so i do like to think about
about that and i think about living
stories as the ones that contain um
i don't know not fact but truth or like
like like useful
um information useful what do you mean
by living stories
um i mean the stories that that
that make it the stories that like
like from a
like i don't know if i i've never
thought about like
like the darwinism of storytelling but i
mean like i don't know the ones that the
ones that keep the ones that survive
yeah there's like a meta process that
you talked about where it's like the
story is about survival but then the
fact that stories survive is also like a
meta version of that this is what i was
trying to point to before the idea of
attention which is that like these
stories survive because we tell them
basically that's what it is like we we
transmit them to the next generation and
that's why they survive but there are
there are implicit reasons why we do
that that it's not arbitrary you know
the you know the the horrible sitcom you
know that in the 90s that we don't even
remember the name of
that we don't remember it and we won't
pass it on because it was just it just
didn't
keep our attention it wasn't good enough
right it just didn't have what it takes
to kind of survive whereas other stories
uh do survive um so mike my question is
one of the one of the things that i've
been thinking about a lot is the
difference between
um
our world which is full of
entertainment stories which i appreciate
obviously i like them i lived in this
world but there's also a way in which
this is much different from ancient
cultures that had
participative story that is the um let's
say the ancient greeks when they told
the stories of the heroes and the the
gods it was that was their heroes it was
their gods it was their story
so they by telling the story they were
kind of participating
in in the story and so one of the issues
i've had right now is that we've kind of
moved away from participative
storytelling uh you know like the way
that you would tell the iliad or or the
gospel stories or histo or the story of
george washington or these types of
stories that are
part of us and and on the superhero
stories which are completely fictional
and that you can't like you can cosplay
but you never really enter into the
world of superman right
right but
but you never enter into the world of
zeus either i mean like if you were a
greek then zeus is your god you go to
the temple you give sacrifice like you
know there's a scent in which you're
you're actually like
if you're uh if you're a
modern person you go to you know san
diego comic-con right like
it's
i those two things don't seem that far
apart to me like the idea that like
you are participating in those
in the story of the greek gods
but
zeus is not going to turn into a bull
and impregnate you
right i mean like right well not you but
your ancestors your ancestors
me the ancient greek person is not going
to like
encounter zeus as a bull right and then
like me as a modern person i can like
adam savage has just made a a tremendous
uh mark one iron man suit and walked
around um
one of the cons in it right it's just
it's it's glorious and it's just like
yeah but he's not he's not bulletproof
right it's not a working he doesn't have
an actual arc reactor
and
but he's celebrating that and they were
celebrating that i'm not sure that the
distinction is
that different well i would say the
distinction is is binding of community
and so let's say you take zeus so zeus
we celebrate zeus right we work with
zeus and then zeus binds us together so
we
and so when we exist
together
right we know that we're all looking
towards zeus as
the thing which holds us let's say it's
usually not zeus let's say athena is
better because zeus is
a little far off there
let's say so athena binds us together
and so we worship latino you know we
propitiate and we do all these things we
sing to her but then she is also the
guarantor of our community functioning
so one of the reasons why we exist as a
community because we have the same god
so in the in the fictional world it's
more complicated
because we don't have these
like so so we we kind of we kind of
celebrate so we sell it let's say let's
say here's a good example so let's say
we go to comic-con or we go to harry
potter event and we put on the thing and
we do the thing and everything uh and
then we go back to our normal life
and
those are disconnected in terms of
causality whereas in a traditional
culture
the let's say the influence of athena
will be felt all the way into the home
when the woman walks in and she lights a
candle whatever they were doing like she
burned some incense or something which
would connect all these levels of
reality together all the way down to
you know like whatever ritual they were
using to
include an infant into society whatever
so it was like it was a binding of an
actual society together where these
these stories are more
they're like
you can kind of participate them in a
very particular thing and then you kind
of go back to your mundane reality
i think about it maybe you have a
solution to this or another way of
seeing it but that's something that i've
done i don't know i don't i i feel like
that's not
i don't know like i hear one of the
things i think about a lot is that like
how my
lived experience is not always the same
as everybody like i i see that this
could be a thing but
but in my experience i just feel like i
see
i feel like those parallels are so close
that it's not
i guess like not
it's tough because i feel like like so
let's let's take the he-man story like
let's say you you had this he-man
experience
you like dressed up as he-man and you
wear it under your clothes as a kind of
part of myself yeah and so so you had
this like he-man talisman which would
which would work for you in a sense that
would also probably remain
he's um to make sure i'm
i'm uh
fun-loving uh so so but the idea would
be that that
they would act as a talisman for you
even where the the he-man investment
would remind you of the values that he
may
uh proposed because he did like there
was more there were morals at the end of
every show like it was like you know you
should act like this and and that oh my
gosh he-man
those guys knew what they were doing i i
think it's great like i think it has
and it works with you like it actually
had almost like a liturgical effect on
you like a
like i i people are going to think i'm
being uh heritage but almost like a
sacramental effect on you like you wore
the thing it formed your values and made
you part of the person you are et cetera
et cetera um and so but now it and so
the question is
does it scale like to me that's the
question like this is why i struggle
with these fictional stories and so
it works to a certain extent but does it
scale like can it bind your family
together like can he-man bind your
family together
like can he-man bind a community
together like hold it
in in a
like is there like would you initiate
your children into he-man
maybe you would i don't know like i i
don't know
i just i feel like um one of my one of
my friends who
who
um
who loves he-man more than i do
uh went to to powercon right this is a
huge he-man gathering he went to
powercon and he met uh the guy who
voiced man at arms and and and man adam
said like he said something very
beautiful to him in the man-at-arms
voice and
the guy like
my friend was like you know tears were
in my eyes it's like it's amazing it's
like a revelation like a little
apocalyptic but i see this i see this
with stories i feel like um to say that
these stories are
i don't know lesser or silly or
uh not as not as important it
makes me nervous like yeah because i
because i because in my life i have seen
people
um so affected by story and and so able
to come together
with
i owe my whole life to it honestly like
like finding my my group online these
flight artists who we all ended up going
on and telling the same kinds of stories
like
like diving into
to this
um
that shaped and formed my life and and
like i treasure the moments that we get
to see each other in in in events and
things and i and i see other people
doing this whether it's the cosplay
community or
um
and and like
it's in it
i can only see the parallels honestly
because like like you go you go to new
york comic con and they're they are
selling you things right like and and
that's gross maybe but maybe it's not
maybe but i mean they were selling you
stuff at temples too like they were
selling those dubs that you sacrifice
right
um there's always people making a buck
off it um
so i don't know and and like now i see
um my my youngest daughter ronia um
she
really latched onto the mandalorian
series
it was really beautiful it was really
good and it was like that's a whole
nother one for me um the
i kind of wish she never took off the
helmet
because it allows you spiderman is like
this um which is why i like like which
white like i cried at the spider-verse
at every time because
they've taken all the
all the responsibility
lessons and all the
self-sacrificial lessons from spider-man
and finally said like
you could be under the mask
it could be yeah i've talked about that
before which i when i talked about it in
the sense that it's like it really is
the desire for religion but it's like a
weird version of it like it's a it's
like it's basically saying you could be
you know you can
you can kind of live in christ or you
could live you know you can manifest
this in the world but it's
but it's it's weird because it's like no
i mean
not really right i mean you can't you're
not spider-man
right but
or you can't like can you i don't know
like
i mean flip the question i'm struggling
to see how how
uh
how how that works the other direction
like how it works so the other the way
it works the other direction is that for
example you can imitate
or you can you can imitate christ
because christ
basically self-sacrificed himself
and that you can imitate spider-man the
same way though by sacrificing yourself
yeah amazing what i may tell spider-man
he's like sometimes
like like a hero what did she say she's
like heroes i believe in there's a hero
in all of us there's like
something that makes us noble keeps us
brave yeah i think that's true for sure
sacrifices and then it says and
sometimes it means
giving up the thing you want most even
your dreams
and that that i i'm still a real sucker
for the
defining a hero by what he wants and
then not giving it to them
yeah
yeah that's i mean i think that for sure
in spider-man that's definitely a
powerful thing about him which is that
spider-man is always sacrificing that
that's his story he's always not getting
what he
would like to have and he has to
sacrifice that to a higher order
right and that's like and that's where
that
yeah i just
i don't see
you don't see the difference i don't see
the difference completely no i i mean i
see how it's beautifully human and i i
see that spider-man is
um
a person
given great power
but we all are in some sense
um i find those
i find that i find those stories
honestly also a lot about um about
puberty really like yeah for sure yeah
times when when you change and you
become stronger
um
men and women happens in different ways
and
same ways in some ways but um because
you just physically get larger you get
to the point where you
um
whoever you are you've got to explore
that in the tantrum now you are a danger
to your parent yeah yeah yeah you
explore that a little bit in the jack
series you get a sense that that's kind
of what's going on with jack as well
like that
in that transition spot there and then
they ha and he has that like he has that
like i feel like zeta zetas
um yeah like i like to have characters
who like have
flaws but they're always going to be
part they can control them right they
learn to control their flaws but they're
not like
over it right like zita's whole deal is
like her stories start because she has a
little bit of an impulse control problem
right like if you give her a button
she's gonna push it like she can't not
um and she probably gets that under
control but it's still her first
impulse right uh jack's one of jack's
impulses is to control the situation
when
i'm gonna do this he's like i'm going to
force you not to and um that's one of
the points where things kind of go bad
for him any and he does it in the next
book too it's like he doesn't quite get
over that um
but i just i
but those are
like all those values i guess i guess i
feel like this idea that like oh some of
the christian values are of of sacrifice
and and all these things are bubbling up
in
in pop
in in maine current stories right
currently told stories but i also feel
like
i don't know what's specifically
christian about those values because i i
found them in in superman and he-man and
spider-man and they just seem like human
values right they they say
and i don't know how the other story is
more how how is it fundamentally
different well if you look at i mean if
you look at
ancient uh epochs for example like the
the theme of self-sacrifice at least the
way that it's presented in the christian
story
is not really there it's maybe hinted at
it's it's sometimes there's something
which could maybe be around it but if
you think of achilles for example i
always give this example
it's like achilles in the iliad is
brooding in his tent and doesn't want to
participate in the battle because they
took his sex slave away from him sure
and and he goes back into battle when
they kill his friend and it's like all
right now it's time to have revenge over
my friend because because he was killed
and he goes overboard and there's all
this going on uh and you see the same
with the like you know
hercules is a hero but he also
slaughters his children like there's a
sense in which the the heroes of the
ancient world are these terrible
kind of figures that are extremely
powerful and that you have to fear and
kind of uh you know you kind of have to
be careful of uh whereas the hero the
christian hero which becomes exemplified
in the night is the hero that
has power which he gives to those that
don't have power
and that's basically the basic structure
of the hero since the advent of the
christian story and and it's so
sort of the less powerful yeah exactly
and so that becomes like a just a trope
and then so you see it in he-man you see
it in superman you see it in every
basically every popular story because
it has
it's been a major transformation like
it's a major transformation the way we
understand
what even hierarchy is like what the
purpose of having these people above us
is is that they're there to love that
which is below right the purpose the
purpose of the leaders is not to just
clamp down on us and and and control us
but is to give back and to kind of to
give themselves for for those that
follow them so that's that to me that's
like the major christian difference
between
ancient stories and and stories even
you find hints of that in buddhism like
there isn't a sense in the idea of the
bodhisattvas who
who refuse nirvana in order to help
those that that are still in the world
and so it's like yeah that's actually
that's quite close to the christian
story but it's not a it's something
which is not
it's not an obvious story it's obvious
to us because we've been living in it
for 2000 years but it's not that obvious
in terms of ancient myth for sure
okay yes
that yeah grant i will grant you that
definitely
[Laughter]
well no i mean like like a lot of the
ancient myths is like like like a lot of
the christian stories the flipping of
might makes right to uh you know uh the
flipping of that power structure right
the the mighty are there to serve the
the weak right um
or that that is
maybe just our human
calling like to to to to to
serve those below us
but i am still struggling to see like
why there's only one story to tell that
really well no there is and it's
fractally effectively wrong with telling
it with spider-man right nothing wrong
with it lesser uh
about telling it with spider-man i think
yeah
once we say like well spider-man's the
one that said with great power comes
great responsibility
so but why can't i make a character who
also lives the value of with great power
comes great responsibility and just
like spider-man's awesome you can go to
spider-man if you want but yeah
but story there are many stories
and the best stories
like the tortoise and the hair are true
right
but
not factual
i guess it's what is is the deal like
like
like there are times
like you learn from the taurus and the
hair you know that very often
uh taking the slower methodical route
gets you to the end first or if it's a
race or whatever yeah
uh but then like there are times in life
when you want to sprint
right like or where that's the that's
the correct call right uh is to just
go sprint but
if that story becomes too crystallized
and formalized and two
and and that there's a there's an act
and if we look back in history there's
an actual turtle that tells you
you've got to take the slow and steady
rate that's otherwise it's it's it's a
sin right yeah and that's
okay
that's the story that's taking the story
is true and then conflating it with fact
yeah right yeah well for sure that these
ancient stories are
they're how can i say this they're more
organic than that like they don't they
don't
like you said
the more that's why in a lot of these
ancient tropes ancient stories sometimes
you'll find uh
you'll find uh like adages that are
actually the opposite of each other sure
and those it coexists together right
because it's like uh you know you say uh
you know is it far from i forget sorry
i'm french so it's like i don't have the
attitude i think it's far from hard far
from mine is that it is that an adage in
english
oh
uh okay i can see that right so you can
say absence makes the heart grow fonder
and then you say far from hard far from
mine yeah they're different yeah right
okay so it's like it's actually two
opposites
so it's like if you're far away from
something it makes you forget it if
you're far away from it it makes your
heart grow fonder for it right they're
actually both true
but they but like you said you don't
want you don't want like it to turn into
a rule system oh out of sight out of
mind out of sight out of mind sorry like
sorry i i just i don't i'm i'm french
people i was like i know it's in there
yeah yeah um anyways but to come back to
the idea of of uh
to me it's all about participation like
i said
that's why i don't see it like you don't
have to see it as a pose i think that
there's a way in which these let's say
the christian story
bubbles down like bubbles up and kind of
fills up and manifests itself in all
these these different stories and that's
great it's actually wonderful that that
happens
um but there's also a way in which
like i said that i mean i i see when you
say go to comic con and everything i get
it like there's something it's not
nothing but it's not it's not about the
mandalorian i don't mean to interrupt
you but yeah go ahead but i feel like
i'm gonna forget this i feel like
watching my daughter
my little daughter um she's 10 and she
she latched on the mandalorian and now
she's got a helmet and we're like making
her some vestgar armor and we all as a
family enjoyed watching this series
together like like like as a as an event
and then now
she plays mandalorian in in the yard
with a friend
and you know like
they've got and they build it out of
legos they build little worlds little
mando worlds out of legos and then also
when we if you play that opening theme
that music that goes along with it
like it's just one of those things where
we're all there right you can blast that
through the house and it's just like
it's not
it's real like yeah i'm not questioning
it it's not quite as formally
ritualized
but on the other hand it's young
yeah but it's also not like i think that
it's the to me it's the like
so let me paint you the other portrait
right which is a village
that has a church in the middle
of the village and the building is
actually higher than all the other
buildings so when you look out your
window when you're walking around you
can always see the the steeple above has
the point of reference for all the
people in the village
and then you know it like in the
catholic village let's say at 12 the
bell rings and then we're all at the
same time in the village
doing doing uh praying together
we know we can't see people doing it but
we know that the entire village is
praying together
at the same time
kind of looking towards this central
space
and then on sundays we kind of go into
the church everybody kind of goes into
the church together then people
celebrate the same thing
and then we move out and we go back into
our homes and we and we have a fractal
version of that which is that it kneels
and like i said uh when the bell rings
then we'll have this celebration we do
together so what it does is it creates
so this is the community is bound
together by this common celebration and
so in in these fictional world which
which like i said it works like in the
mandalorian
what happens is you have these little
things that pop up
but it's ultimately you because we're
watching society kind of fragment
so like our suburbs are just
you know suburbs have no center suburbs
have no place of communion right suburbs
have no common goal or common project so
it's like this breakdown which and it's
manifesting itself in all these little
little smaller versions of liturgy like
you said say the mandalorian or marble
or star wars and all these or manga or
whatever
um but ultimately it's you can feel this
breakdown yeah
okay no i mean i've lived there so i i i
will
i have that village
yeah i totally totally because we we we
we've spent um
you know all all put together um you
know we'd go for it to the gravonia
montale in italy this is where my
my wife's family is from
um and it's a little
little village like like i think at its
height maybe like 300 people live there
now it's more like 60. um less than now
because it's it's very old um in the
middle of it it is you know the church
highest point more or less it's on a
mountain slope so it's
um bell rings uh
san bartolomeo is the church i've you
know i've marched with son bartelo mayo
and his played skin okay
in the procession around the town um
and it's beautiful right like i i
totally grabbed that it was it's
beautiful but
and it's binding true right and and i
can see that
that is healthy particularly for small
communities to have um
um
but i don't know and i and i also will
like i don't know how to solve the
suburb problem i i get that that's a
and i apologize for this guy out here no
worries
he's having crazy time um
but i guess my i guess my thing is like
like
it's great that
and so you would say would you say like
the ancient communities with
like the greek communities had something
similar
yeah they definitely did yeah they
definitely did and i mean i think that
it's a traditional trope i think for
sure the difference is that let's say in
a roman or greek community
you had that pattern but it was
it didn't have the it didn't necessarily
have the love part as
this aspect that we talked about which
is that at least ideally there's a sense
in which
the father is also there to
help his children right it's like it was
a more
hierarchical thing where the household
would just submit to the father and it
was which is something which exists in
the traditional christian world as well
but at least in the story and in the
ideal there's a sense in which there's a
there's a top-down thing kind of coming
down as well and so i think it's a
totally it's a universally traditional
system
uh it just the difference is in my
opinion in in the in the christian story
you have
a balance between
this kind of top-down structure
and right the idea of how the the lesser
all the smaller people are are the hero
image that we talked about the idea of
the person above giving themselves for
that for those for those that follow him
and all that kind of stuff yeah
uh-huh but it is a universal pattern
it's not it's not just a christian one
that's that's a that's 100 sure
which which part's a universal pattern
that that the idea of binding ritual
like the idea of a
ritual of celebrating you know of
sacrificing
uh you know all of these gestures that
we pose to kind of connect ourselves
with something higher and then bind
ourselves to those that are around us
okay so were the greeks
in their rituals
were they like were they more closer to
what you'd say like
like
the
mandalorian or marvel cinematic universe
or something like that
what do you mean
well he keeps saying like well it's
different with these fictional stories
yeah right were the greeks operating
under a fictional story no i don't think
so
okay so they asked me if i think the
gods exist yes i think that gods exist
and zeus zeus included i think zeus
exists of course the gods i think i'm on
a neil gaiman side with that i think all
the gods exist
sorry i guess you didn't expect that but
no this is super interesting like like
how do like how
in what way
maybe we're not understanding this maybe
we
don't know the maybe we're not using the
same exist in the same way
i don't know how do you use the word
exist
uh
well i mean
are you saying they exist in the way
that an idea exists
they exist in a way multiplicity becomes
one like they exist in a way that
they're that they are
uh principalities that manage
uh bodies that manage
that manage aspects of reality
hmm like
you're a little bit beyond me i'm not
exactly sure what you're saying
so i'm totally interested though i'm not
i'm not i i am interested i'm just i'm
just i'm struggling this is like this is
like the worst thing to start into like
an hour and a half into our discussion
but
not the he-man stuff that's right
we can drop the humans um
so so in that so think of it like um
okay so let's say a city right right and
so
is it does the city exist
sure right but it's but it's also i mean
where like it's a
it's a very it's a very fluid thing like
it's a body right it's a exists material
it exists as an event as well right but
it's so you can be it you can for
example be a new yorker but still like
be in miami for example like you could
you could you could participate in new
york but while physically being in miami
yeah yeah all right so it exists so the
way it exists is complicated it's not a
simple thing so it exists under
something like a principality right in
scripture there's that the idea it's
like the angel there's an angel of a
city
and it's a and it's a it's a it's
it's a being just like
you have a bunch of stuff in you like
you your body and your body extends even
into your books and into your
the things you say online and the you
know the the notes that you've written
right it's like your body is a lot
bigger than what we think when we think
of you just as this guy that is there
let's say that i could you know they
could touch or that's right in front of
me right you actually you're but your
being extends beyond that it's not it's
not as contained as sometimes we think
and so the way that you
like
that there's a part of you or an aspect
of you which is one
it's like your spirit
your soul like whatever word you want to
use the pattern which unites all this
multiplicity that makes it recognizable
that exists at different levels of
reality it just
just doesn't exist for people it exists
for for cities for
exist for passions which is why we say
they're demons like the demon of lust or
the demon of this like it's a coherent
body which is managed by
a pattern which is
what do you mean
which makes you recognize it is a way to
understand that
can a demon
affect the material world
of course but not not materially
not materially not directly yeah just
like your thoughts can affect the
material world too
not clearly
like your will can affect can affect the
world you just just not materially your
will doesn't affect it directly
so you you can so you can you can have
spiritual action at a distance right you
can ask your wife to bring you a cup of
coffee
and if she does then you're affecting
the physical world through meaning
through spirit right
hmm
that's that's a lot that's a lot to chew
on all right sorry
can i ask another question like what
about like so okay so zeus in some sense
exists
could there be a new one could there be
new gods that will exist well they
wouldn't be new
they would they would they would they
could they could their bodies could
appear in time that's for sure
so like so like oh so we discovered new
gods that always did exist
well that not always the word always is
complicated because it implies
how can i say this it's like you could
say that all things exist eternally in
the mind of god is the best way to
understand that and then they manifest
themselves in time and space but that
they they obviously all of them have an
eternal
like a non-space non-time existence
so so of course they could be
they but i would say it may be yes and
no like it's complicated like of course
all
so there's a theory like a thomistic
theory and it's a it's a theory that a
lot of ancient christians accepted which
is that it's every time there's a
communion between
between beings there's an angel
so there's myriads and myriads of angels
like you know every time like there's an
angel for our conversation
because the because our conversation is
more than the sum of its parts
are there angels for our tangents
what do you mean by our tangents
is there an angel for the he-man part of
our conversation and an angel for the
uh the uh like is there an angel of
he-man no no it's like you say there is
an angel for our conversation for the
communion for the fact that we're that
we're coming together like
the union of multiplicity into one so as
soon as multiplicity kind of joins and
you can recognize something but they're
just angels
they're what are they distinct yeah
they're distinct angels they don't
necessarily have another podcast is that
a different angel or is that the same
angel coming back for the next podcast
the next location where we doubled down
on all this stuff
um it'd be interesting it'd be
interesting to think i don't know
where's that that's a that's a that's an
idea that doesn't really have an end
no it doesn't i mean that's why it's
like there's that's why the i'm not
saying that this is necessarily the best
way to kind of understand reality but
it's definitely a one which ancient
christians have have thought have have
accepted not just integration like even
you know like it's it's a even in
hinduism you have this kind of idea
right that there are myriads and myriads
of of principalities
okay
but it's the problem it's a problem of
complexity like it's it's not it's not a
religious problem it's it's a problem of
how we're able to perceive unity in
multiplicity
because it's like you think it's obvious
that that you have a bunch of stuff in
front of you
and all of a sudden you see it as one
thing it's like why are you seeing it as
one thing it's not one thing it's a
bunch of things
and that bunch of things also has
another bunch of things at a lower level
right it's a stacking up a bunch of
things but then somehow you're able to
perceive
one
so how is it that you're this one where
is it
right so that's that's the that's the
ontological problem that these questions
are trying to propose it's not a it's
not a it's not a new it's not a new
philosophical or physics problem right
where does one thing and the other thing
begin like
but i mean like i don't know i've been
reading a ton of physics and
and it is
it gets slipperier and slipperier the
more you look at stuff and that that i
can that i can get on board with yeah
and and i do like like the idea that the
edges of things
the reality is granular and the edges of
things are are kind of fuzzy yeah they
have margins and they're they're like
the corners of the fields right that you
need to leave until they're the
or the the fringe on the vestment the
fringe of the garment there's a there's
a messiness on the border sure sure sure
but i'm
i don't know i just i can't
i struggle with with
with talking about principalities in
angels as
in that sense
as being
useful
for understanding it like at least it's
not
the most useful thing in my toolbox
currently
mental toolbox i guess i'll say that
it's like i'm not i'm not going there
it's it's
like you're coming up with some
interesting stuff but i'm struggling to
get it i guess yeah that's okay i mean
it's not i didn't expect us to go in
this direction anyways in this
conversation i'm like i kind of drew
kind of pulled you into uh
into uh into a world of a world that's
difficult it's not the way that modern
people think let's say uh but it's
definitely
it's something that is it's coming up in
the problem of complexity and the
problem of uh
problem of emergence like how is it that
these how do these phenomena coagulate
into
one right how is it that quantum fields
stack up
so that you can say
you know it's like you can say that's
ben it's like that's a pretty intense
it's a pretty intense thing that i can
notice you that you have unity because
you you're you're you're a bunch of
stuff not just a bunch of stuff in space
but a bunch of stuff in time the fact
that these join together
into one being
is something which is difficult to
account for
unless you have something like
a platonic
structure like uh
it doesn't it skills that exist outside
of everything they the one true apple
right but it's not in in that's why in
the christian vision or at least in the
orthodox vision it's not that simple
it's like it's not just that the apple
the form of the apple exists
outside the apples it's that it exists
within all the apples and the apples
exist within it it's not a it's not a
it's not disincarnated it's an
incarnated uh metaphysics you could say
so it's not like there's a world of the
forms of apples
right and then there are the particular
apples it's that this is actually
this is it's an incarnate reality but
the form of the apples are you could say
hiding in the apples and the apples are
in the form so that you're able to
perceive
the apples
as a discreet thing
it's like sorry
i feel like i feel like this is going
like way off to the kind of thing but
let me let me let me kind of let me rope
it back into the yeah all right
talk about
the storytelling
well i'm talking about i'm i'm thinking
like the one
i guess i get nervous when when
all of it leads to there being
one true story
which is also
definitively historical and therefore
has primacy
over
every other story like the story of
jesus relegates that relegates all the
other stories to being glimmers of the
one true story and that
is an idea that i have grown
uncomfortable with yeah
yeah but there's another way to present
it which is not which is not necessarily
all the idea that they're just glimmers
but that
there's a
how can i say this there's like a
fractal reality which is that reality is
full of
let's say the story of logos right right
but that's the logo so logos the whole
thing you're giving a fractal reality a
center
yeah
that you mean the fact that it that that
the story of jesus like encapsulates
let's say all these stories together
and then by definition has to be factual
in a way that the story of zeus is not
historical
um
i mean was do you mean you mean that
it's that well zeus was it was is not
embodied
in the swamp
i don't know
take it i why am i on a zeus kick today
that's so weird yeah but any one of the
people who was uh who zeus dres like
turned into animal
zeus and and got pregnant yeah
today um why are we talking about all of
zeus's rapes that's what you're
wondering yeah yeah yeah it's a
interesting psychological question going
on here um
but did that happen like is like
so you could say that it didn't happen
in the same way that we say that the
story happened george washington crosses
the delaware or awake what's uh the
signing of declaration of independence
right and so so there's a hierarchy of
events in the world and and they don't
necessarily happen at the same level you
know and some of them have more
intensity and more brightness and some
of them are less incarnate also as well
you could say um and so for sure the way
that the way that zeus impregnated his
different uh ladies is not the same way
that
we talk about the resurrection let's say
or that we talk about the story of
christ but
to say that it didn't happen i think
do we talk about the resurrection of
christ in a similar way to the signing
of the no i hope not i hope nobody does
that like because it's it's obviously
not at the same level it's a different
level
it's hinted at in the scripture right
closer to the zeus level than to the i
mean the idea would be that it's a it's
a kind of
it's a place where it all comes together
and so in a way it is
something that happened but something
which is beyond description at the same
time but it's not a it's not a it's not
a fable at least no christians believe
that it was a fable like that it was
something that happened in uh in the
more subtle way let's say so a lot of
the a lot of the old stories are more
subtle like they have they don't have
they're
they seem to be happening at the psychic
level or seem to be happening at the
like the
a psychic level of the virgin of a
community like something like that like
you know how you have ideas and
imaginations and so the day a community
can have that as well and so a lot of
these stories seem to happen at that
level
uh
and so they're not exactly the same as
um
as i say the stories about jesus
okay so but story okay
so yeah those stories are happening at
more of a psychic level
which is different from the story of
jesus
was it happening at a more psychic level
than say
uh ford making the first
um
uh uh team model t
i don't know
yeah you're trying to find something
that is historical well we're on it
we're on a we're on a we seem to be on a
um
on a on a
there seems to be like uh
uh what do you would call it
a conte continuum of some kind
of types of events yes so like like we
have like the more psychic events which
are like like zeus we have more
historical events like like the the
first light bulb
um things that you can like point to you
have you know
and then we have like where where on
this continuum is say the resurrection
i don't the resurrection is
is very singular because it's presented
as both an event which obviously
happened
in a way that people could recognize it
as happening like it's happening in the
world but it also points it's it's it's
difficult to contain because the
disciples don't recognize jesus
they don't recognize him and then they
do
when he reveals himself and so it's a
very it's very mysterious i think it's
made to be mysterious
it's made to be mysterious on purpose so
that you don't think that it's
it's as mundane as you know you cutting
your fingernails
uh but that it's also not something
which is
imaginary or a fable
but that it somehow is a place where all
of this kind of comes together
and that's why it's got primacy and we
can
toss out zeus but not that
we don't have to toss out zeus like i
mean we don't worship zeus but people
remember the story of zeus right about
things that bring communities together
it does not have to be it does not have
to be athena yeah well the the stories
of the greek gods ended up participating
in the margins of christian civilization
like they were remembered and they were
they were remembered and uh copied and
celebrated as
lower on the hierarchy of things let's
say to remember but they weren't
forgotten like there were statues of the
greek heroes and constantinople of the
roman heroes and greek heroes and
constantinople like they were you know
they were just part of society but then
the norse myths are alive and well now
with thor being in the marvel universe
yeah
so it's like so i get like that but
that's that's more of the the evolution
of story like that's
that's an organic
i don't know uh
like stories in time growing changing
being adopted by different people for
different reasons and different ways um
yeah but there are ways like i mean be
interesting to look at it because there
are ways
in which the story of the story of jesus
let's say just the actual story of jesus
that it takes storytelling to its limit
and so it's very difficult it's very
difficult sometimes to go to think
imagine how you could go beyond some of
the stories that are told today in this
story
that they did
sorry go ahead no go ahead you go ahead
i'm sorry i'm i'm i i get excited and i
interrupted it
so like the story of the of the
descendants of the underworld is a good
example that i like to use which is that
the descendant of the underworld is like
a universal story you see it in every in
every culture it's always there like
there are versions of it different
aspects of it and you go down
to visit to get some wisdom you go down
to save someone you succeed or you don't
succeed uh you know
and so you see it in all the in the
epics and you see it in the the
different myths and so so now jesus has
a virgin
which is to go down into the underworld
and then he goes down into death
and then he takes everybody out
and then he destroys death
and so that's
like that's the end of that story so
it's not like i mean you can participate
you can have other versions of it still
like it still kind of fractally will
continue to manifest itself but it's
reached the limit of storytelling
which is that that story of the descent
into the underworld has has kind of
reached its
yeah like their death is abolished
so
[Music]
so i mean it's like you could say why
did why is it that they're the ones who
thought of telling that version like i
mean you could kind of find
that but if that's the one if that's the
one true best ultimate
version of that story the fullness of
the underworld story
as me sitting here i have two questions
that's the firs so first question number
one with that being the fullness
of the underworld story
um
i i sit here today with the book on my
desk is writing an underworld story yeah
that that i feel that that marginalizes
my underworld story a little bit
but like why would i why would i the
best has already been done
all i can do is be a glimmer or a
fractal reflection of that story
right but that's not like the idea of
being a fractal reflection of the
ultimate story is something that it's
that's always what we've been doing it's
not like it's not
it's not like this is this was always
what's been going on like it's always
been a fractal reflection of some story
which we recognize and then we're kind
of participating in and we're showing
different sides of and and so and then
everybody can kind of see that this is
this is connecting us to something which
we can't totally describe or that stirs
us in a way that we can't completely
exhaust
um but that continues to be true
because because because it's because of
the point let's say where that story
comes together has been
has happened uh it doesn't mean that
there isn't this like joy of
participating in it i don't know i mean
i it doesn't it doesn't affect me like i
i would still tell an underworld story
because
dante still told an underworld story and
it was one of the best underworld
stories to ever to ever happen but it
didn't reach the limit let's say of the
of the of the story of christ like it
didn't it actually participates in it
because it even in dante's story you you
get this sense of how
all of this is going it's been
transformed by that event and how it's
also even more interesting hints about
how
yeah anyways i won't go into that but
yeah sorry
okay
so what about um
this sounds sincere like i'm having a
hard time figuring out where the the
line is between
and then you're
the way the way the way we're talking
about now is it um
takes a lot of thought um
but i i have i have this idea like
do you think if you
could see the historical christ
jesus of nazareth will say
um
and find that this is a historical
person
and could could view that history or
travel back to that history would you
think you would be disappointed
um
because
and the reason i'm asking can i just
just go ahead and flush out that
question my other totem that i have here
with me so i had prince adam i also have
uh robin hood yeah
who i love and uh my daughter angelica
gave me this uh plastic disney robin
hood because i love
disney's robin hood uh right but you
know like
robin hood's
hard to figure out where it all came
from
but you know they're it's possible that
they're they're like a couple
um
like early early medieval contenders for
maybe the origin of the robin hood story
i feel like if i went back and met one
of those guys
with you know disney's beautiful fox
robin hood with errol flynn with um the
many other versions in my mind it would
be nothing short of a disappointment
yeah
i think you're right but i think that's
part of the story it's actually in the
jesus story what you're saying
and in the jesus story is people being
disappointed
in jesus
and not him not seeming to be
what they expected him to be and so your
your the way you think about it is
completely right but it's contained in
the story
so there's a sense in which the logos is
hidden in his manifestation and the
fruits of that
of his hiddenness appear
as the story continues to unfurl and so
when when christ resurrects that you
know or when the when there's uh
uh at um when they receive the holy
spirit you you get a sense that all of a
sudden now they see
all these little aspects of his story
and they're able to connect them in a
way that at the time they were too blind
to kind of see but i think you're right
i think that probably
if i if i was there especially without
the knowledge that i have now
i would probably be one of those people
that didn't recognize the messiah
because
because he because yeah that's exactly
how the story is actually told
interesting
that's good though
this is all very interesting stuff
um we should probably we should probably
go i mean it'd be nice to have another
conversation
because it's like
i have run out of questions you run out
of questions well listen i i i'm sorry i
took you on this crazy this i didn't
expect it to gonna go in this direction
no pride
it was a wild ride so thank you thank
you for your time and thank you
especially for your your books and uh
and once again i want to encourage
people to to especially if you have kids
that are
you know kind of middle school age even
from like i mean younger is fine too and
even in your in for adults as well like
they're just really great stories and uh
very positive and very boisterous great
characters so i really appreciate what
you did what you've done and i'm happy
to uh
i'm happy that you were willing to talk
to me oh thank you so much it was it was
a pleasure all right and also maybe
remind people of the upcoming book julia
julia's house goes up really quick
this is kind of my job to plug this book
i feel so yeah you have to you have to
plug the book julia's house goes home i
had a blast um particularly illustrating
this one with my watercolors so i'm
happy with the story and and it's a i
feel like it it ended well enough so
and and and ben think about all the
things you talked about let them all
over i'll also think because you really
provoked me more than a lot of people in
terms of the picture story and it's like
i've been just saying this and now
you're like oh i'm pushing here so i'll
think about it as well and maybe we'll
have another conversation at some point
maybe we will thank you so much all
right it's good to meet you
i want to present you a new series of
graphic novels called god's dog
god's dog is a very loose and epic
exploration of the legend of the
dog-headed warrior saint christopher one
of the most surprising and peculiar
traditions of the ancient medieval world
it was written as a screenplay by myself
and my brother mature over 10 years ago
and the story was taken up and even
recommended by script scouting agency it
was requested by several hollywood
studios
but this story was of course too big too
strange too surprising for hollywood
and so now
with all the control of its potential we
bring you this groundbreaking story the
full color as a series of graphic novels
the story is set in a token style
mythical version of the biblical world
filled with hidden codes ancient relics
angels giants dragons and populated with
fictional virgins
of mysterious monks warrior saints
and more symbolism than you can imagine
god's dog contains all the intensity and
subtlety of our symbolic thinking the
world class layouts and artwork of cord
nielsen all of this bound in a
mysterious and powerful story arc which
is available to all
from wide-eyed 10 year olds to the most
seasoned of readers
the entire story with all its action and
complexity is already completely worked
out and the first book
is near completion
now all we need to do is deliver it to
you
we're crowdfunding this because
it is only the first step
we've already been contacted by even
international publishers for this but we
want to knock this out of the park so
that our artists can do this full time
and deliver the oncoming books at a
regular and steady pace
under our control
i myself will personally not be taking
any profit from this first book but
rather i want to use this to build what
we need to tell this full epic with all
its cosmic proportions
so along with a graphic novel we are
also producing a crowdfunding only
add-on the secrets of god's dog source
book a beautiful volume in which you
will find my original drawings for more
than 10 years ago an exploration of the
symbolism of saint christopher
and an exclusive text by matsuya pejo on
the symbolism of the biblical samson
this is the first thing that methio has
published since his groundbreaking book
the language of creation
so jump into the margins with us be part
of this shift in storytelling where the
end becomes the beginning and where the
monster carries the king
into a new world